you have to remember district 14 is made
up of a lot of immigrants a lot legal
immigrants they came from socialism they
don't want it they know what it's about
they're disgusted and what's going on
with the crime out of control AOC wrote
that letter a few years ago stating that
police in our Subways is racist look at
our subways
Subways they don't want that they have
to close their businesses early they
came here for the American dream and the
American dream is being ripped from
everyone in the 14 districts even across
the country we're being controlled by
there you have the Democrats the house
senate and the presidency they're
destroying our country with the 14th
District is really taking a very hard
hit because of AOC
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the Republican candidate for congress in
New York's 14th District running against
AOC Tina Forte welcome to the Reuben
report
thank you for having
me I'm doing well Tina I said to you
right before we started we talked for
about 10 seconds man on accent alone I
want you in Congress that you are like
New York all over you how are you born
and raised in the Bronx in the district
actually in the district right like
actually in the district that you're
running for
yes I was born and raised in the Bronx
in Throgs Neck went to Saint Francis D
Chantel graduated Preston High School my
first job was in the district got
married in the district raised my kids
in the district I have a business in the
district I am the district
so I sense that you did not think that
politics was in your future but perhaps
AOC dragged you to this is that fair to
say
yes she everything dragged me to this
but more so I don't see because she is
representing my district
I am not a politician I'm a mother
grandmother small business owner and
after covert I just had enough I started
ranting in my car
started building momentum and a
following and I just was speaking to
people and I was going to rallies and
protests I still were business owners
during the lockdowns I spoke up for our
children in school with the mandates I
spoke up for our city workers I backed
the blue I was down in the city with the
law and order the big beautiful Flags I
would walk in the streets with and I
just became very vocal and I'm fighting
for the people and I want my voice to be
for the people yeah speaking of your
voice I can tell you've been you've been
out there screaming huh it's tough
giving speeches every day yes I am I'm
talking every day to have covert damage
so that has a lot to do with it because
I did almost die from covid Wow and I
have esophagus damage so it weakens my
voice wow well you're I'm strong fourth
day strong and loud
as I said to you right before we started
we we could use some more Italian mamas
in Congress I think that really could
could fix this whole thing up what can
you tell me about the 14th District uh
where obviously you're you're from and
and business as you said and Grandma
there and all that stuff because I think
people don't really have any
understanding of the district other than
somehow AOC magically appeared in this
place and now she's on the front page of
everything all the time you have to
remember district 14 is made up of a lot
of immigrants a lot legal immigrants
they came from socialism they don't want
it they know what it's about they're
disgusted and what's going on with the
crime out of control AOC wrote that
letter a few years ago stating that
police in our Subways is racist look at
our subways
Subways they don't want that they have
to close their businesses early they
came here for the American dream and the
American dream is being ripped from
everyone in the 14 districts even across
the country we're being controlled by
there you have the Democrats the house
set in the presidency they're destroying
our country with the 14th District has
really taken a very hard hit because of
AOC she's not here to represent the
people and when she goes to a town hall
the people go there they listen they
want to hear what she has to say if
she's gonna back the blue no they sat
there for an hour hour they were very
respectful they listened to as soon as
the first man stood up and asked about
crime she would not answer and the crowd
got angry and she danced and she mocked
them and she was condescending and she
was rude and that was a disgrace and as
a congresswoman you have to represent
the district on both sides left and
right you have to be their voice you
have to listen to them if you don't
agree with them so what she did to me
was discussed and she won't debate me
I've been calling her out I show up to
our town halls I'm outside with a
microphone I said to chicken top office
a live chicken with a scientist aoc's a
chicken debate me oh yeah
where is that chicken now
the chickens fall under all the
districts she actually ran off to
California
she said in her first town hall in
Columbus High School in the Bronx that
she was not leaving the district
at all she would be in the district up
until the election while she ran to
California and guess what she got
heckled there she can run but she can't
hide
when you saw her come down to my state
during covet as she had you guys locked
down and masked up and she was for uh
you know forcing people to get
vaccinated and everything else and then
she was drinking uh I think Margaritas
down on South Beach I'm guessing that
didn't go over too well
she's a hypocrite same thing when she
goes to our town halls she walks in with
security the NYPD is outside with the
cause and the signs on yet she defunds
them
she's a hypocrite and I think everyone
now sees her for what she is like I says
she is a candidate a congresswoman from
wish that's so cool the congresswoman
from wish yeah they got it and now they
see that she's ineffective and they want
to refund
do you think that people not only
because they're seeing the crime and
then all the coveted stuff and all that
like the stuff that's obviously on the
ground there but also that she has just
tried to be a political star this whole
time where you never hear her talking
about her District actually ever I mean
she's not ever she's on every show every
weekend you know treated with kid gloves
but I never hear her talking about the
Bronx
um you know she's trying to be a
national star
well she used the district to push her
radical love to judge she auditioned for
the part remember she did have an
audition literally auditioned for the
party yeah she literally auditioned for
the part and she used the district to
push her agenda I call her AOC all-out
communist that's what she is
she's a little she's a little socialist
darling of the Democrat party and we
don't want it the district doesn't want
it I don't think the country wants it
either see more and more people waking
up across the country to these Democrat
socialists of America does it strike you
as a as a very odd thing that the
progressives that they're for all of
this crazy gender stuff and all of the
race stuff and all of these things that
if you go to the Bronx I honestly cannot
I've been to the Bronx a million times
in my life like like wandering down the
street nobody would be for this stuff
it's just it's so disconnected from
what's on the street that really pushed
them over the edge they don't want that
creepy weird stuff going on in the
schools you know American values need to
be told in our schools we need God back
in schools we need God back in our
country we have to get rid of these walk
policies woke does not fix anything it
does not fix inflation does not fix the
education system does not fix crime it
walk is useless
just like AOC
but tell me how you really feel are you
getting any uh are you getting any
support from whatever the Republican
Machinery is in New York I know it's
very kind of out of whack over there and
although I have to go on the record I
think something good is happening with
zeldon I honestly think there's a chance
we'll see but is there any Machinery in
the Republic from the Republicans that's
helping you
no it's me my Grassroots have a very
small team it's basically me and my GC
and a couple of volunteers and that's
really it I'm just doing a really strong
Grassroots campaign I have no help from
any any RNC any Pax I was in a primary I
forced the primary
on New York I was the only one in New
York that was not backed by the GOP and
I won the Primary wow because I'm a
fighter I don't park down I Stand My
Ground and I'll always be that way
that's why I can tell you that I will
make changes for district 14. I will
fight for everyone
so you were not backed by the GOP you
win your primary and then did they did
they call you or do they just ignore you
after that did they just think that this
is a far gone conclusion the Bronx GOP
chairman called me
he was very you know he's working with
me he's very nice to me
um that's really it but at first they
did not they did not have my back
interesting but I lost the primary on
them yeah
is it odd that you're do you think that
you're not getting more uh attention I
mean when I reached out to you on
Twitter I was kind of like wait a minute
it almost for I almost forgot that AOC
was up for re-election everyone is right
now and then I was like wait a minute
obviously I got to get this woman on the
show
and no one talks about her race no one
talks about it like I said as if I
didn't push for I had to petition twice
so if I didn't push for a primary I
wouldn't be here the hand-picked guy
would be here
yeah
to be quite honest with you don't call
them out you have the conservative party
chairman Pat McManus in the Bronx who's
left the conservative guy on the ticket
despite me you're not spiting me you're
just fighting the people of the district
who are you taking votes from the people
are going to not going to get the change
they want if it's a very close race and
you leave somebody there just because
you think you're speeding me you're not
spiting me yes fighting the people so
you don't belong as the chairman you
mentioned the policing before and
obviously aoc's hypocrisy where she's
wandering around with armed guards while
she's gone to defund the police and all
that kind of stuff how uh in the in the
couple years that she's been in Congress
how has the security situation or the
safety situation I should say how has
that changed in the Bronx
it's horrible
there's no more plain clothes detectives
there's no more police on our subways
they lost their qualified immunity
they're they're cut all over so they're
working double ships it's it's sad then
the way they're treated is a disgrace
they're the real heroes a First
Responders are the real heroes a
policeman a fireman or EMT workers what
they did to this state and to the work
is is disgusting they go out and they
want oh they want to praise football
players for taking a knee to our flag
look I have my American friends tattooed
on me my dad's Marine bage tattooed on
me my dad's Purple Heart tattooed him
I've Semper Fi on my neck I love America
I love this country I carry Wounded
Warriors on Spartan courses before I got
sick with Colvin I carried them I also
carried a coffin with 22 dog tags to
raise awareness to veteran suicide I
love this country and it needs to go
back to real American values so what is
going on over there that she even got
elected in the first place I mean I get
it that a lot has gone wrong since then
and then covid and now the wokeness is
very obvious but how did it even happen
there well Joe thought he had it in the
bag Joe Crowley I think that was his
name he just didn't show up to his
debates and he wasn't in town basically
the same thing she's doing now he just
forgot about the district just like she
did and now you see the tides turning
what time that when she comes into the
district she's booed out
and she then talks about the district
that's how she snuck in she got in she
made promises she didn't keep them she
went in and says oh I'm different I'm
not the establishment no yeah you are
you are there you're worse than the
establishment
she's worse she brought communism into
New York she put socialism into New York
she is I like that she's worse than the
establishment and she really is you know
one of the things that I've been saying
about her for a while is she doesn't
realize it but she's actually the past
of politics she thinks she's the future
of politics but I actually think all of
her divisive obviously I don't like the
ideas but even just the divisiveness and
the using groups against each other
that's not what the future of this
country is she's managed she's done a
trick on us I'll give her credit she
became a star but that's it
that is it and she can't relate to the
district
she claims she can she can't she's not a
mom she doesn't know what it's like to
have I'm a grandma too she doesn't know
what it's like to send a kid to school
with a mask on and have all these
mandates and to have you know real
issues to worry about money she's not
like that now she goes to the Met Galas
she drives her Tesla she has security
around so she lives she's living the
light of a the life of an elite and she
left her District behind the district
she promised to fight for
I'm guessing uh probably because of some
of those videos of the of the protesters
at her things she's probably not
spending a lot of time at the home
District at this point right she's just
in DC all the time no she fled to
California
's coming back but the chicken's out
there looking for a
I really want to know more about this
chicken I love this chicken idea this is
going to become like a real thing oh
it's on my page
Congressional page you'll see my you'll
see the chick all right we'll grab it
we'll grab the chicken we'll put some
pictures of this chicken
um I noticed on your on your uh Twitter
bio you say America first I'm curious
what what does that what does that mean
to you because this is becoming sort of
the new trend and you can feel a little
tension now with the Republicans are we
America first or are we you know sort of
old school Republicans whatever that
means then then you have all the
disaffected liberals who are kind of
coming over now you know who are waking
up and going okay something's not right
what does that mean to you we need to we
need term limits we need America First
Patriot to put America first Americans
should come first look in the district
we just had a problem with the they sent
the illegal immigrants to Orchard Beach
in my district
I'm not gonna lie I went to Orchard
Beach on October 1st and I protested
because at aoc's policies the open
border policies that she pushes for the
sanctuary cities they decided to send
the illegal immigrants and house them in
Orchard Beach give them security
give them food
give them heated tents we have homeless
we have homeless veterans in our
district so I went to Orchard Beach and
I said no not in my backyard and not in
any backyard this should be send them
back
send them back and let them wait online
so I declare October adopt an illegal
immigrant month in Orchard Beach come on
down 81 million strong take an illegal
immigrant home with you feed them clothe
them give them shelter but get them now
out of the district
wow and I went great you know they said
they started coming call me racist they
were shot by the three rallies protest
rallies back to back to back I didn't
care I went out and I say it like it is
you know sometimes I'm harsh but I'm
real can't take that from me so you
didn't want to uh you didn't want to
bust them straight up to Martha's
Vineyard instead
that's what I said I said why don't they
go to Malt this bit you know I said God
they were sent there 50 of them were
moved by the National Guard the next day
and they would fed Cheerios with people
with rubber gloves they didn't even get
a hot meal
so when they show up you said they're
getting food they're getting security
they're getting housing and then and
then I suspect she well for a while the
Democrats in New York were pushing to
have illegals vote so I don't even know
where that stands at this point but you
could kind of see what's going on here
that would that was shot down by the
courts and the illegal immigrants are
now out of Orchard Beach they did move
them to Randall Island so we have to
protest there even though they're not my
district they're still up to fight for
because it's something I believe in
believe strongly about that they
shouldn't be here at all we shouldn't be
housing them at all they need to go back
online go back
go shut the border
I got it I got it I'm curious what do
you what do you think uh the chances for
New York to really turn this thing
around I told you right before we
started I'm born in Brooklyn I grew up
in Long Island I did move to LA about
eight years ago but I'm in free Florida
now you know when you hear Kathy hochel
say if you don't share our values go to
Florida I mean she's basically talking
directly to you she's talking to half
the state but are you hopeful that New
York can turn it around because it
should be a great state and New York
City should be the city that everybody
wants to live in but it's not how it is
now it should be and I do believe that
there is going to be change I really
feel good about November 8th I do feel
that a lot of Republicans are going to
be winning on November 8th I think Lee
zeldon has a really great shot of eating
Kathy
he really does and I really feel a lot
of momentum in the district I was
endorsed by Reverend Ruben Diaz from the
Latino Community the Bangladeshi
Community the Jewish press I got all
endorsements by democrats they're
they're endorsingly they're embracing me
they want freedom I'm fighting for
Freedom it's good versus evil it's
Freedom versus government
nobody wants that they're so out of
touch with Americans that's why I say
America first you're putting us last we
belong first even people that came over
here illegally they came over for the
American dream we're all being pushed to
the side it's not right
Tina you remind me of every single one
of my friends moms growing up in Long
Island I wish you a lot of luck and and
I I really think there's a chance and as
I keep saying we just gotta get to a
point where in America we can look in
that back mirror and say AO see you
later enough of her so if people wanna
if people want to support they want to
help you out where can they go
Tina 40 for congress.com
t-i-n-a-f-o-r-t-e-f-o-r congress.com
Tina I hope we're swearing you in thank
you so much for having me God bless you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell